well millions of children in this
country and around the world now face
several weeks possibly months in various
degrees of lockdown or confinement at
home experts fear it will take a
significant psychological toll on
families across the globe
The Hollywood superstar Goldie Hawn has
spent years helping develop a program to
work with children and their mental
health it's called mind up and it's
trained over 150,000 teachers and helped
nearly 6 million children well she was
supposed to be talking to me here in
London this week instead she's safely
shut in her home I hope she's safely
shut in her home in Los Angeles and she
joins me now so Goldie thanks very much
for joining us and I mean you know
stress and anxiety among children must
be at very high levels with this
shutdown that you're experiencing many
people are experiencing around the world
this sudden confinement yes and what
we've been trying to work with children
for all these years started in after
9/11 and it was because our children are
going to inherit the rest of this world
we have to make sure that we take care
of their emotionality to teach them so
we're teaching how about their brain and
how it works and I want to share a
little bit about that today because we
have a lot of research on this it's
worked we have to manage our emotions
Romo was saying just not recently I am
going to manage my emotions now I have
to get things done and afterwards I will
be able to give everyone a piece of my
mind well when we're living in small
quarters one thing that I want our
parents to know is that they too need to
create an atmosphere for children it's
very hard because our brain is on alert
and when the amygdala in the brain of
the limbic system is alert then we don't
think well and that's what it what's it
about a sort of hijacks
our thinking it hijacks our ability to
feel happy it hijacks our ability to
give our children what they deserve so I
know there's it's very hard to be locked
up but if you can think of
wonderful things to do with your
children keep them positive don't fight
with your spouse don't fight with your
children reactivity is one of the most
dangerous things for our little ones so
we do have on our website which is mind
up dot org dot uk' i mind up family that
we've just launched go to that there are
many things we can do and and i really
feel i feel this so deeply mind up has
been a great i sorry just want to ask
you go to you mentioned there that you
started it after nine eleven you saw the
impact on children's mental health then
you decided the law yes the program do
you think this will have a similar
impact i think that it will for sure one
of the areas that we can look at okay so
because i'd like to we have positive and
negative we have you know let's look at
things optimistically or pessimistically
when we look at the ability of our
families actually being together or that
we get to zoom together or FaceTime
together we realize really on the
positive that we really get to spend
very very important time together and
it's why we have to look and create a
calm in our own mind because that will
allow us to actually be in this moment
with our children in this moment because
one day everyone this won't be happening
we will eventually come back to normal
and and this is where we have to
actually look at this and say right now
we are going to do amazing things at
home we'll have our little corners we'll
have our little games that we do and mom
and dad contagion and anger and hurt and
fear is also very very contagious to our
children they will experience it
themselves so we do a service to our
kids and the service to each other don't
fight don't be angry at each other just
love your children that's all we have to
do and specifically i mean if you
there's a mom or dad you know in a small
house with the children and the children
are agitated they're stressed just what
a couple of things they could be doing
well one of the things is is I will say
that I worked with mine candy which is
an app and I created a basically what we
do a brain break it's a form of a
meditation I suppose but really it's
short but it gives children and parents
and the whole family an ability to get
down sit down together and quiet and
calm our minds and it's really been very
effective the other thing to do is to
create games together to tell positive
stories because the way the brain works
the more positive energy you have the
neurons actually fire together they
wired together so we want to be able to
give these children the ability to think
optimistically in times when we are
basically catastrophizing about what
could happen if you obey the rules if
you stay inside if you really really do
then you're doing everything you can do
and you'll probably come out okay so I
think there's an opportunity to be a
little bit more optimistic yeah well
look it's good advice just I mean before
you go what do you make of the whole
situation oh that's a really good
question it feels very very surreal in
terms of where we are today but I will
say this I've never felt more connected
to the world I've never felt more of one
piece of the whole world and we're all
in the same boat together our emotions
are just flying we have to be able to
hold hands together virtually and know
that we need each other and I think this
is something that will come out of this
is that we all care it doesn't matter
whether we're rich or poor or any of it
we have each other and if we can't hold
on to that I think we'll have more peace
in the world
and that's what I think all right well
and you are okay are you you you locked
up there I mean yeah you all right I'm
fine I'm locked up I'm praying for
everyone's good health and that this is
over soon and I just know one thing if
we think of others sometimes we
we feel better sometimes that's a good
thing to do is to think about other
people not just ourselves it'll help
your mindset and your state of money and
how do you think your governments
dealing with it how is Donald Trump
dealing with it do you think I'm not I'm
disappointed
okay well he's not doing enough for you
didn't do it quickly enough oh no of
course not I mean that's very clear this
stair was you know a lot of personal
observations which is not what we need
we need the facts and we need to act
quickly and you can't dream this away
this is real and everybody knows it so
can't pull the wool over our eyes we see
it okay so yeah going going going no I'm
just gonna say I mean I think that
without you know being cruel which is
not my nature I think there was a lot of
mistakes made I really do I think we
could have gotten a much quicker head
start on some of this okay and just
finally away from the politics your
message to children around the world who
may be feeling very nervous about what's
going on remember that sometimes bad
things can happen
but then what takes the place of good
things and we have to remember that this
is a limited experience this is not your
whole life just like when you feel
sad or angry or fearful those emotions
will go away and what will replace them
it's a happy emotion let's focus on that
all right
goli good stuff and I hope well I wish
you well through all this and thanks
very much thanks very much for indeed
for joining us : thank you for having me
good bye everyone stand grateful thank
you very much